all right hello and welcome to our first
ever Nature Publishing Group journal
Club
so I'm Alicia Newton I'm an associate
editor at Nature Geoscience and I'll
also be your moderator for the next hour
as we're gonna discuss climate
variations over the last two thousand
year so it definitely wouldn't be a
journal club without a paper and today
we'll be focusing on a recent Nature
Geoscience publication called
continental scale temperature
variability during the last two
millennia so the page is 2k can soar I
wrote this paper concern consists of 78
authors we've got two of them here for
you today so don't worry I'd like to
introduce first Thurston Kieffer he is
the executive director of the pages
organization and was also the driving
force behind the 2k reconstructions for
more detailed look at the climate
reconstructions themselves we have Nick
McKay
he's a postdoctoral researcher at
Northern Arizona University off the
other list we've had got narrowly
Abraham's
she was formerly of the British
Antarctic Survey but now is Australian
National University and thank you for
staying up so late to join us
she was actually working with the oceans
to UK group so they're doing a sea
surface temperature reconstruction
that'll be complementary to the land
surface temperature reconstruction we're
talking about today and she's also the
lead author of another recent Nature
Geoscience publication that
reconstructed melt on the Antarctic
Peninsula over the last thousand years
last but not least of course we have
Gavin Schmidt
who has kindly woken up for us now Gavin
is a climate modeler at NASA I guess and
also you'll probably recognize him as
one of the founders at a frequent
blogger on the real climate blog from
London of joined by my colleague Michael
angin Berg she's the chief editor at
Nature Geoscience and she's actually in
charge of relaying your comments and
questions to our panelists a lot of
times you might see her as a black
screen
that's okay she's still with us she's
just hard at work looking through these
questions at this point you're probably
wondering how do I ask a question
well we'll be monitoring Twitter please
use the hashtag hash and pgj club and
also the google events page if you're
joining us from YouTube or the up
schemes and memes blog we're
unfortunately not much
monitoring those climate scheme streams
so head on over to Google and Twitter
and then we'll take it from there
great so right now I'm going to turn the
discussion over to Thurston who's gonna
tell us how this work all came about
Thurston here you go thank you very much
Alicia I'm probably as excited as you
are about this so this this first
hangout is not only the first nature
geoscience hangout ever it's it's also
basically the first major harvest of of
the pages 2k network project and the
harvest is due to a seed that was
planted like seven years ago and was
planted and actually in South America so
there we had a pages workshop and maybe
I should say what what is it what the
organization in the back of all this
network is and Loretha maybe can get us
slide 2 so that is that is pages in the
middle you see you see the big logo and
pages is an international global
organization that facilitates the
science about past climate and past
environmental change it has a number of
sponsors down there from Switzerland us
and be hosted at university of bern in
switzerland and pages houses many
activities but by far the biggest I have
to admit is the pages 2k network so this
this had its it started these seven
years ago in South America so toucan
hearing scientists from Argentina and
Switzerland they they had a workshop a
big workshop bringing together people
from all over South America and such a
success that they the idea consolidated
to to produce a climate reconstruction
to pull all available climate
paleoclimate data of the last two
millennia and and try a reconstruction
of regional climate change of a quality
that has not been seen before I said
that that's took off and the word
spreads and then came groups from other
regions Antarctica and Europe and the
Mediterranean
we'll also thought that they could open
up a regional group in their region at
which point any pages with it we said we
should go serious about this and how
great would it be to have a network of
regional groups and regional
reconstructions covering the globe so
you really set up this this this this
call and the enthusiasm was great so in
the end now we have a continental scale
group and reconstruction from from every
single continent the last one was the
continent without a population not
Arctica and in the end as Alicia
mentioned even if the people working in
the ocean they found that they actually
also have something to contribute
and one of Harvey's ago they opens the
the ocean to K Network or group where
nearly is a major player so this is
where we are today maybe you can get
slide number three it shows what I've
been talking about right now it shows
all the groups and funnily enough you
see a little bit the evolution you see
that the South American group and the
Arctic group they still produce their
own logos
whereas at a later stage really
providing some corporate identity so
this is really grown and and it is
perfectly fine for all the groups to
design their own strategy and and so on
and you can see this now if you can have
the first figure from the paper itself
actually it's a slide for you can see
that we default all the way through to
leave groups there they're the regional
groups their own freedom to decide do
you have slide 4 we don't sorry we're
having a little bit of a problem it's
like only not another problem so the
point being that the overall strategy
was that every group should produce a
regional scale picture of climate change
and that we were ambitious to go back to
two millennia and we wanted everyone to
not only focus on temperature in the end
but also on other climate parameters
like precipitation and maybe pressure
fields but the choice of methods and the
prioritizing answer was all left down to
the groups which is why we now have a
fairly heterogeneous product with all
these strengths and weaknesses which I'm
sure we will discuss Thanks hey great
thanks Thurston um Nick I'm gonna ask
you if you can tell us a little bit now
more about what you found in putting all
these reconstructions together sure
thanks um so we had three main
conclusions and and because like forsen
was alluding to then there's um each
group had both the advantage and
disadvantage of being able to organize
their methods to best suit their own
their own region and their own records
and so both how that a sort of selected
in screen for records and how they
process those data and how they
ultimately turn that into a temperature
reconstruction was all decided
independently and and that's good and so
in that we had regional both
representation and reason
regional expertise in each with the
associated with each clan nails color
region but it's bad when you want to
start trying to compare regions because
then if you see differences or see
similarities you don't know the extent
to which those what you're seeing is a
function of how they how they went about
doing things as opposed to you know a
real each here in the climate system so
for this paper wheeler just go step back
and try to focus on what's what appear
to be the most robust features of the
data and in all the regions and we found
three main things so could you go to
slide 16 yeah no so the first and
predominant feature of all in all the
records with this millennial scale
cooling trend this had been well
observed and then in the northern
hemisphere in several that paper is both
for northern hemisphere wide
reconstructions Arctic reconstructions
your can read instructions but to see
this in the southern hemisphere was a
bit surprising like we had to sort of
attribute it to or others had attributed
to changes in precession the northern
hemisphere but that they can't explain
what's going on the southern hemisphere
as well or at least it requires a bit
more of a complicated explanation so
that was a really interesting result the
second main conclusion we had which is
can you go to the next slide maybe I
should take take a step back here and
explain what all these colors are that
you're looking at because you haven't
looked at before it might be a little
bit jarring but here if you see in each
row there's there's there's eight rows
and the middle road North America has
sort of two smaller rows superimpose
each of those corresponds to one of the
one of the pages two K regions in the
paper and then the colors correspond to
how warm or cool those records are with
respect to the period of overlap between
all the records so if it was if it's
yellow or red or orange it was warmer
than the average whose name 1200 and
1965 ad and if it's blue or so let's
take one of the various shades of blue
it's below average so as you see this
that long-term millennial scale cooling
trend is this shift between
these redder colors on the left towards
bluer colors on the right I'm accepting
the 20th century so the the second major
thing that we found and could you go to
is this sorry I think that I need the
next not this slide there's a slide 17
probably yeah sorry 17 you want the next
one um sure yeah that's the one I want
yes oh I think there were there was
animations within the slide that was the
problem I wanted to go back to the last
one and step through it right there
I think oh yeah yeah so superimposed on
that soup on that long-term cooling
trend we see this difference differences
between the regions in these sort of
century two multi-sensory scaled warm
periods so they sort of commonly
referred to Medieval Warm Period and
Little Ice Age we see that a shift
between warmer conditions earlier and
cooler conditions later happening at
different times and different regions
and this is important and suggest that
there's a lot of sort of continental
scale or regional complexity that might
get masked if you're looking at a
hemispheric or global average that seems
to jump out when you look at smaller
scale regions and then the third major
conclusion and you can sort of see it on
here too and I alluded to earlier is
that at the end of this long term lineal
scale cooling trend all the regions
except for Antarctica show pretty abrupt
and dramatic warming in the 20th century
this is this is a pretty robust feature
of the dataset and and as I mentioned we
wanted to make sure that what we're
looking at wasn't due to you know how
that how they reconstructed how each
group group decided to reconstruct their
data but rather that was so robust
features the data set that showed up no
matter how you look at it um so we we
went about standardizing and doing some
simple reconstructions that making
similar plots of these which I want to
show you but um if you go to figure I
think it's 9 yeah
this one here we went back and we're not
looking at reconstruction at all now
we're just looking at each of the
individual records and so what this
tells you is for the upper for the upper
panel it tells you which thirty-year
interval between 1500 and 2000 ad was
the warmest in each of the individual
records which went into these these
reconstructions and and then this is
it's a similar plot for the bottom line
except for it's a hundred year skip so
if I centuries and goes back to 500 AD
so so it's clear that that warming trend
we see at the end of all the
reconstructions is that it's a sort of
coherent feature of all the individual
records which are going into the
reconstructions and the 20th century
shows up is quite anomalously warm at
least for the past thousand years
they're really sending back further so
those are the three main features we
focus on in this paper great thanks for
that um neroli I'm actually going to
turn to you Nick showed us a actually
broad long-term cooling trend in
Antarctica but from what I understand
that's not what you actually found going
on in the end of it Peninsula can you
tell us a little bit about that yeah so
so we've been working on an ice call
from James Ross Island which is right
near the the northern tip of the
Antarctic Peninsula and it does show a
different story looking at the 2k
continent region results I would say
that the James Ross Island temperature
reconstruction actually looks more
similar to what's happening in South
America compared to the main Antarctic
continent so so at that site we actually
have a long-term warming trend from
about the coolest conditions being
around about 600 years ago and then we
get progressive warming from there and
then we do get an unusually fast warming
since about the the late 1920s
great thank you narrowly um so Gavin I'm
gonna turn this over to you we keep
talking about the climate of the last
2,000 years climate of the last thousand
years why why should we care about these
climate changes over the past two
thousand years so there are two main
reasons why people care one is to
actually find out about what went on
during historical times whether there
are connections between climate events
and and and you know historical events
that happened that might shed some light
on you know civilizational full collapse
change and and I think those things are
very interesting and I and I love
reading about them but my my interest is
is slightly different I'm interested in
the records that we have not just over
the last two thousand years but over the
the Paleo climate history on a much
larger scale in order to test out
climate models so we've we've built
these current models they're complicated
beasts you know roughly a million lines
of code and you know we're trying to to
make sure that the physics within them
and the parameterizations are as best
rif or as good a reflection of what we
see in the real world as we can make
them but these things need to be tested
in cases that are out-of-sample they
need to be evaluated when you give them
a climate change where you try and prod
them when you try and understand their
internal variability what we're trying
to do is we need we need we need
examples from the past for us to be able
to say how credible the predictions of
these models are for the future and and
that's a really key issue because of
course we're making predictions for
climate change in the future and they're
you know they're twenty years thirty
years a hundred years out it would you
know we could just wait around and see
if they come true but it would be nice
to to see whether you know we could we
can improve that
ability ahead of time so that we can
have a slightly more confident view
about what's going to happen and the pay
your climate record is is really the
place where we can go for that because
the changes in the Paleo climate record
are on the order of the changes that
we're going to see in in the future now
different points in the Paleo climate
record give us different insights into
what what we can what we can judge about
about the model so over the last 2000
years we've had a lot of a volcanic
activity that has left a mark on the
record we've had a lot of solar
variations that have left a mark on the
record we have this long term trend that
Nick was discussing that seems to be
associated with orbital factors and of
course if you go back even further we
have you know we've got much much bigger
changes associated with the ice ages or
with the with the with the ternary that
changed this from the Pliocene etc so
what I'm looking for in these kinds of
analyses and these kinds of synthesis
are points where we can look into the
data and look into the model runs and
we've done dozens of model runs now for
this exact period it's well I mean so
for the last the last portion of say
from about 850 to the year 2000 we've
done lots of lots of model runs using
state-of-the-art models that are being
used for all these projections going on
into the future and what we'd really
like to be able to do is to compare the
output of those more runs to these
synthetic well in this synthesis of the
data that tries to take into account you
know all the different little individual
problems with any individual record and
tries to come up with the bigger picture
for what's happening and the questions
that we can ask ranges from the simple
right you know does the global mean
temperature look kind of like the global
mean temperature and the answer is yes
kinda to the more subtle which is you
know once the frequency of extreme
events what's the frequency of droughts
are these things connected to any of the
four
things can recalibrate the forcings it
is it is quite subtle it's not just a
question of well how cold was the mill
ice age and how warm is the medieval
period which which a lot of people tend
to focus on but actually those kind of
hemispheric scale things then they're
not actually very constraining because
we can make it globally warmer or
globally cooler just by you know playing
with the with the forcings which are
uncertain themselves so the four things
the things that are driving climate
change
great thanks Gavin um as we talk sort of
about climate of the last millennium I
think we probably can't avoid mentioning
the what's right or wrong we become one
of the more famous reconstructions of
climate of last millennium B Oh
inevitable hockey stick and in some
senses this is being called the new
hockey stick reconstruction and
certainly I know narrow least gotten to
know you known as the ice hockey stick
reconstruction but um so this original
hockey stick was published in 1998 by
Mike man and this shows a fairly stable
actually flat temperatures throughout
the last thousand years before the
inevitable quick rise in me quickly
interrupts um I I was looking just the
other day it's where this reconstruction
falls in terms of the the error bars on
them on the original man reconstruction
it falls pretty closely within it and so
there is a long-term decrease in that
reconstruction as well and then the
pickup in the 20th century which is
actually not that different to to what
what they presented great that's
fantastic
so and and that was actually a northern
hemisphere based reconstruction as well
so that then tell us we think the
northern hemisphere is saying like
driving this climate change is it the
northern or could it be the number of
records from various regions um other
people could I think perhaps
but I think my my guess would be is the
variations in the southern hemisphere
are just smaller right there's more
there's more thermal inertia in the
southern hemisphere the response is
slower and that's true for the 20th
century forcings
as it is for responses to volcanoes or
solar so my guess is that most of the
variability that you're going to see
will be in the northern hemisphere and
and it will be mostly in the land
portion rather than the ocean I think
those are just kind of generic aspects
of the climate that are going to be true
for almost everything that's going on
can I actually ask you what do you think
we've learned now then since this first
hockey stick and this massive
reconstruction obviously there's more
data but have we learned something more
subtle about the climate system through
this time it's been 15 years since the
first hockey stick okay yeah I mean sure
I basically I can repeat the conclusions
that nake presented I mean and I can I
can I can follow on from what Gavin said
that he says his he guesses that the
southern hemisphere is just an
attenuated version then in terms of the
climate history compared to the northern
hemisphere aunt I mean we now actually
have have have date data and that's I
mean that's that's a major achievement
of this this reconstruction that the
southern hemisphere was was pretty bleak
a few years back now we have full
reconstruction from South South America
a full one from Australasia we have
Antarctica so we can fill the southern
hemisphere with the data and we actually
see place while surprising to some
results of a cooling trend over the last
two millennia I mean like like why is
the southern hemisphere is a key player
in identifying the pattern
of Multi Centennial variability is what
used to be the Medieval Warm Period well
with with with over the global view of
all the regions we we know we can see
now that it's it wasn't warm at all at
the same time in all regions so and
since of why people rather use them and
the medieval climate anomaly as a turn
consequently we we now have the the data
that supports these ideas of regionally
diverse multi centennial climates
behavior so I guess in talking about all
these regional reconstructions
we're not mentioning Africa which in
this case I guess in the paper it said
there wasn't really enough to enough
information to go about making a robust
record that we could be confident in
Nick can I ask you or is there any hope
that we can fill this gap in the future
are there records that are untapped in
Africa is there some way to fill this
gap or is it just going to be a mystery
to us absolutely I think that the past
2,000 years in temperature in Africa is
it's looking up I know of several
records that are that are coming online
there's new techniques being developed
generally speaking it's it's relatively
difficult to get temperature records in
Lowell at two regions because in my
environment smacked in lower latitudes
tend to be more sensitive to hydrology
but there's some news or cute chemical
and other approaches that lets you sort
of extract the temperature signal from
the hydrology signal and so yeah I think
is a handful of records coming online in
Africa that I think maybe the next
iteration we will make a better go of
Africa other hand Africa is an enormous
continent and I think that most of the
records that we're going to end up
getting out of it are gonna be from East
Africa because I think that our picture
from West Africa and Equatorial Africa
might
be pretty pretty sparse still for the
next several years merrily um speaking
of taxis it's actually surprising that
yours is one of very few melt records
actually in the Antarctic continent can
you tell us a little bit about why
they're rare and what these records are
actually recording yeah so for
Antarctica there's only been two
extended reconstructions of melts that
have been recovered so so there's one
published a few years ago based it's a
cycle dome and then there's the the new
record from James Ross Island that we
have just published in Nature Geoscience
so so I think at first it seems unusual
we've got all these ice cores from
Antarctica why do we not have lots of
records of note we've got lots of
records of what the temperature was
doing it doing but the melt is is this
interesting feature where you actually
need something like a bit of a
Goldilocks sight if you're at a site
where the temperatures are too cold then
summer temperatures still don't get
above that zero degrees Celsius
threshold for melting and that's the
case for the majority of the high
Central Antarctic Ice Sheet so that's
why from the number of records from
there we just don't have any information
about melt on the other hand if you go
to a site where there's too much melting
then actually the the melt destroys the
climate record so it's very fine balance
between actually not too cold so that
you get melting but not too hot that you
destroy the record so so that's why
they've been so hard to to define and to
get a handle on how melt has changed in
the past so that I think is really sort
of one of the the unique parts of our
record and it was certainly not the
primary aim when we went out to drill
this ice core it wasn't until we started
drilling it that we realized that we
were actually pulling up this quite
amazing archive great thanks so much I
think we've actually got some questions
in coming through again Google and
Twitter so I'm going to turn it over
you hike up with our first question from
the audience okay so we've got a Google+
question from Michael Evans and it's all
about the reconstruction and it's what
is the uncertainty in the representation
of the 2k legions that's the boxes in
Figure one by the Palio data how do we
project onto figures that's a very fair
question perhaps you could just talk
about the reconstruction uncertainty in
a yeah I'd be happy to Mike Mike I
always ask really good questions so yeah
so just like with the rest of the
reconstruction each of the groups
handled air in the reconstruction in
their own way
and so it's okay it can be a little bit
challenging to know how you know if
you're trying to compare air between the
two and that's and the extent to which
sort of air bar is shown and I think
it's figure s to you know whether the
width of those if they're wider in one
region compared to another whether that
means that we really understand that
region better or sorry worse or whether
they just sort of factor it'll more
things into the air the handling of air
and Paleo climate records you individual
records as well as this and then
especially in compilations is is a very
challenging thing to do there's a lot of
sources of uncertainty and and typically
you have to sort of cut yourself off and
focus on on you know certain aspects of
you know of uncertainty the things to
think you can wrap your head your head
around so whether it's the crowd
calibration to temperature or sort of
the you know it's maybe there's there's
a bias as a seasonal bias and some of
the records it might be more sensitive
to to say summer temperature than annual
temperature whereas other records and
your reconstruction might you know have
it have a different bias and most of
these records are annually resolved and
there isn't any front chronological
certainty
some of them it's I think the Arctic is
the only region that has anything was
one record from South America that has
our lake records which are
annually layered and so there's also an
top of this sort of uncertainty in how
they filter temperature is also in
certainty and timing which adds a whole
new layer of complexity so without going
into too much of the details of Mike's
question that's sort of a brief
description of uncertainty and may for
the most part we didn't formally deal
with uncertainty when we are comparing
the between regions just because it was
it's hard to be able to get the
uncertainty to place where it's you're
comparing apples to apples Nick I'm
actually gonna pick on you again and you
were talking about how much continental
make variability there was between the
sites
did you actually what happens when we
start looking at smaller scales like
breaking up for example Western artists
generica I mean maybe I'll leave that
snarly but looking amongst North America
are we seeing a lot of variation within
the continents as well but you know
obviously can't get put into the
continental scale records there's I mean
I don't know how a cent to which I can
speak about sort of sub regions there's
a fair amount of variability just within
within the records that within all the
records that which make up any any
reasonable reconstruction um actually
there's a good figure for this I'm not
sure which number it is hold on each
action figure 10 so is this kind like
the last figure we're looking at
actually - or we should be that one show
this bar that showed which century is
the warmest you can see that in that
last one we're looking at actually go
back to figure 9 Olympic let's talk
there first and I'll go to upload of ten
so though here so you know so this is
this is this figure nine here we're
looking at all the records in all the
regions and just where they're warmest
and you can see despite the fact that
that's sort of the 20th century warmers
really coherent there's there's more
records that that you know there's just
there's lots of records that are warmest
in you know
elsewhere in the record there's a lot of
variability that shows up across records
so it's it's not the same everywhere
it's just we're sort that's why we sort
of focus on the major patterns now you
can go a figure 10
this is a similar sort of figure but
instead of looking at which interval was
warm a century or three years warmest
we're looking at you know how many of
those records show show that sort of
long-term cooling trend that ways it's
the probably the most coherent feature
of the data set and so what you look at
here is as you move from left to right
you're looking at a different at the
start of the interval that ends in 1900
so the some of the furthest left you're
looking at the records that go from you
know 180 to up to 1900 E and you can see
that still that we see you know more
than almost 70 percent of them shows
significant cooling trends and more than
80 percent show show cooling trends but
even there which is the most robust
feature we still see something like you
know 18 percent of records which are
actually warming up at that interval so
so yeah there's that there's a fair
amount of internal variability between
proxies within each region and then
especially globally alright um Gavin I'm
gonna go over to you now um can we
capture this variability in models so if
you look at models outputs that's
smaller and smaller scales
you see greater amounts of variability
at all - at all time scales now whether
the variability in the models is the
same as the variability in this
reconstruction I don't think it is but I
have we haven't done the the analyses
that that would really pin that down yet
I think it is kind of important to note
that some of the variability that we're
seeing in these reconstructions might
not be climatic right you know we're
mixing in a lot of things stuff happens
to Records and you know and not
everything is is perfectly David or
perfectly calibrated as as Nick was was
pointing out so when we're looking at
these records they're giving us a hint
to what the natural variability was or
the the variance between the different
regions but there's still a potential
that that might be
overestimated because we have you know
too many noisy proxies because they're
not they're not very good they're not
very I didn't have great fidelity to the
record and we're mixing in lots of
different things which I'm very
different characters so you know the
character of the lake valve sediment is
very different to a tree ring which is
very different to a coral which is very
different to an ocean sediment or a melt
their proxy so I think what we're going
to be developing over over time is I
think more of a forward model approach
so what we can do now is compare you
know the the synthesis that you get from
these records to the the mean quantities
that you get from the models but I think
a better way of going about it is to try
and embed within the models you know the
processes that produce an isotope record
or produce a tree ring or that produce a
melt layer and then what we be able to
do is to say okay well here we're
producing melt layers at at this
particular grid box and now we can
compare that to griddler melt layers at
narrow Lee's site directly or we can say
oh well here's a synthetic tree ring
that we would have produced here in this
boreal region and we can compare it and
then when we synthesize that I think
we'd have a much better idea of whether
the models and the data are coherent
taking into account all of the different
sources of uncertainty but we're not
quite at the point where we can say that
yet okay great
so talking about this variability and
you've pointed out a few causes solar
irradiance
volcanoes changes actually in the
Earth's orbit around the Sun we call the
insulation
are there any anthropogenic changes that
are forcing these things that we see
land-use changes in land use changes in
land cover as we DeForest things I mean
certainly this these activities are
detected in the archaeological record
going
several hundred years back Kevin uh yes
so the reconstruct the the model our
experiments that we set up that do the
last millennium and they do include
estimates for land use change and land
cover change over that period those are
a little bit difficult to to estimates
you know beyond the historical record
but people have made good estimates of
that though there is some spread on that
so we've we've used two different
reconstructions of land cover change
based on different assumptions about how
you know about how how much for instance
the the Americas was deforested before
the arrival of Columbus so there's some
uncertainty about that but we can we can
put that in detecting changes that are
just due to that in large scale climate
records is is hard and and I'm you know
a lot of people can see you can see
local changes exactly where these things
are happening but the impacts on the
continental scale is quite noisy and and
it's and it's quite hard to detect but
that's certainly something that we're
thinking about
we've also of course included the small
changes in greenhouse gases that may or
may not be anthropogenic over that
thousand year period uh but but you know
I mean we're trying to include all of
the drivers and then we're trying to see
whether those drivers can produce his
detectable signal and and we're not
quite done with that yet great thanks
Marilee did you want to comment on that
yes um yeah um I I just wanted to follow
up on Gavin made a really interesting
point about how we come about to being
able to move the science forward by
comparing the proxy data with the models
and and so one of the ways certainly in
ocean to UK we're looking at this and
using this opportunity where we have all
of these cmip5 runs where we have models
that have been run with transient
forcings
over the last 1000 years and it gives us
a way of actually being able to compare
a little bit more apples to apples and
to bring together the data with the
models to say do the models explain do
they look the same as the time series we
get from the reconstructions but Gavin
made an interesting point about putting
into the models actually what the
proxies are so putting in tree rings
putting in isotopes and so the question
for Gavin was how close are we to having
models that we can run for these long
sort of transient simulations that can
can do that what sort of what's your
feel for where the modeling community is
on that well it depends on the proxies
and the amount of work that you need to
do is also a function of the proxy so
for instance all of our thousand year
long runs included water isotopes and so
if you're looking at an isotope record
in corals or spelly of themes or ice
cores or cave records okay then then we
where we can do that now for things like
tree rings we I mean people like Michael
Evans who who was mentioned earlier on
have been developing forward models for
tree growth that give you a tree ring
estimate based on phenomenological
models of phonology and knowledge
complicated word that begins in the pea
models for how trees actually go and so
I think we're in a position to do to do
that as well and those that looks very
promising
for something like Lake valves I think
you'd have to you'd have to have more
input from people who knew about the
regional hydrology exactly what's going
on in these lakes and I think there's
certainly room for pages to help to help
build an archive forward models than a
site-specific that week that we could
then use to process the the output from
these models so that would be kind of
like a
downscaling directly to the proxy but
that requires that requires the people
who know what their sites look like and
what the hydrology looks like to be to
be kind of to help us out with that okay
yes I took a note I mean thank you do
this or support this and I completely
agree that full word modeling is a is a
great opportunity and yeah it needs to
bring together the expertise of those
knowing their archives and those knowing
how to how to build model on this
general topic of data model comparison
with you mentioned repeatedly maybe
shouldn't remain unsaid that's another
key feature of of the of the paper or of
the elf the whole initiative is actually
that that we really tried to provide the
data bases of this paper to really
provide them in in good order and
homogenized in quality control for
everybody to download so if someone is
listening here and wants to play with
the data find out about uncertainties
about variability and maybe do some
completely new research on that basis
you can do that all on the on the on the
new our website for downloads so that is
it it's maybe a new a new phase of
research where it's not just about the
paper itself but about the data as well
and if you want to say something about
the data um I was I was just going to
commend Thorsten for exactly that I
think this has been a very impressive
collection of data and and I know that
that sometimes these things can be a
little bit problematic but they're
getting so many different
groups to contribute and to you know and
they've already got got authorship on
this on this progress report and and
hopefully that's going to encourage a
lot more groups that they're looking at
similar data or that they haven't
published yet to get involved so I think
this is this is a very good marking
milestone in this particular field and
as Thorson said I think this is the
beginning point of this investigation
it's certainly not the last word and and
I think but we're in a much better
position now to do to do a lot more
interesting science along these sorry
sure why don't we pull up a figure that
we can look at this one of the one of
the grids like 16 should be fine
actually go to 17 when they do the clean
one yeah how about that that's great
okay so so the interval was sorry 1200
to 1800 is that right yes 1200 to 1800
okay yeah so I mean clearly the interval
from especially the test of ladder box
there from sort of 1580 to 1880 there
you know the 19th 18th and 17th
centuries are quite cold let me there
there clearly the coldest you know sort
of centuries across all regions in the
record
before that I would say it's pretty
mixed I mean between Zay you know twelve
hundred and fifty and it really sort of
depends where you are it's in Asia it
looks like it was it was pretty cold
consistently but in the Arctic you sort
of have you know a couple centuries of
colder that's slightly colder than
average making a couple centuries
slightly warmer than averaged the way
that this is plotted the way is defined
is that the is that for each of these
regions they average between 1200 and
1965 has to be zero so so you know
obviously the 20th century is a bit
warmer most of them so if we were
looking back to 80 under that plan makes
it on average slightly cooler but I mean
this is sort of one things that we found
and yet and and obviously and then the
cold interval you know near the end of
the records contributes to that sort of
long-term cooling trend that we observe
by that sort of I think the earlier part
of that record I don't I don't see that
the interval of long serve yeah 1200
1500 is being uniformly anything
globally so thinking of that Gavin and I
might turn this over to you we're not
seeing these coherent little ice age
Medieval Warm Period in this record and
I think they've argued for that is it
time to retire these terms um you know
I've often you know I it's really it's
really hard to say one would like to get
rid of terms that are not useful
I think defining periods
climatologically is not useful so when
people say all whisks instead of the
early Holocene they say the the policy
in climate optimum you know it there's a
value judgment in that there's an
assumption that it was all the same
everywhere
um Medieval Warm Period I think has been
in in decline in in most paper in most
kind of scientific usage for a while now
because you know it isn't so coherent
periods in in in that sense um the
Little Ice Age you know that that that
that kind of
pre-dates a lot of the discussion that
we're having now and so I think it's
it's a little bit more entrenched and so
it probably won't go anywhere people
will still will still refer to it
particularly for for things in in Europe
where it is quite clear um so yeah I
mean I would be much happier if people
started talking about the climate of the
12th century or the climate of the 13th
century and discuss you know what it was
looking like globally where I was
looking like hemispheric Lee what I was
looking like regionally and those things
might not all be the same but you know
given given the circumstances that we
find ourselves in I think that's
probably more wishful thinking than than
some practical plan I think I raised my
finger basically to an earlier point
which I forgot now I might actually talk
to you because in addition to your work
on the pole you've actually done a lot
of work in the tropics looking at the
Indian Ocean and Pacific Ocean and what
are we seeing a lot of the continental
records don't cover the tropics so what
I receive in the oceans at this time is
it looking like what's happening on land
at least in the tropics
more generally yes so the the ocean 2k
project is doing pretty much what the
Continental project is done but based in
the oceans and in the oceans we've got
two types of Records pretty much so
we've got the marine sediment cores
which cover longer periods of time but
give you a lower resolution and then in
the tropical areas so the marine records
are global that in the tropical records
are regions we also have corals and they
give us a much shorter climate
reconstruction so usually sort of about
400 years is sort of getting to serve
the the limits of what we can
reconstruct using corals using as a
continuous record
they give us a very high resolution so
we get sort of annual or sub annual
resolution in in those records and
that's basically how the the oceans 2k
project has separated at the moment so
we have the group that are working on
the low resolution records and applying
a systematic approach to looking at
those and we have a group cool working
on the high resolution records and
applying a systematic approach to those
and and now we're bringing those two
aspects together to to get this overall
picture of the tropical ocean of the
global oceans so that work is still
underway I would say that our
preliminary findings don't disagree with
any of the main points that are coming
out of the the continental
reconstructions for the tropics there
are a number of individual coral records
that have been published showing that
there is a warming trend in the in the
tropical regions and that's just from
individual published records so what
we're working on now is synthesizing
those and seeing what we can say about
the temperature changes in the tropics
and then also globally on a
lower-resolution scale fantastic nick
narrowly talked about having some
different proxies and i know in these
continental scale reconstructions these
tree rings lake bars
cave deposits um but these records
aren't just telling us about temperature
so I was wondering did you have any
trouble subtracting like say have
precipitation and signal from the tree
rings how did you guys handle that yeah
so each group and on that differently um
actually let me is a useful figure for
this I don't know let me look check the
number of early wick figure for nothing
what it's not working
oh is it working now yeah okay so this
shows the proxies that each region used
in terms of its proportion what you see
is a sort of first-order if you look at
this is a lot of that sort of medium
dark green which is Trine's
these reconstructions and most you know
past millennium or past two million a
memory constructions tend to be
dominated by tuning records you can see
there's there's some deviation from that
obviously in the darbuka it's it's
entirely ice cores in Australasia they
included a number of coral records that
and so and then in the Arctic which was
the most sort of multi proxy they they
have a certain variety of things tree
rings lake sediments marine sediments
the attempts
so as you yeah like you said all of
these proxies record climate somewhat
differently and as Gavin mentioned
earlier there's um there's only a
component of the sort of record there's
there's sort of the climate component or
especially if you're interested in a
certain parameters the temperature
component and then there might be a sort
of precipitation component and there
could be sort of a you know biological
component if you're looking at tree
rings or ecological component and so
there's a lot of things in there and so
that this is the primary principle both
on sort of this scale of reconstruction
of the e mail local reconstructions is
that you're looking for the sort of
common variability between these sites
which is most readily explained by
climate because that's the thing that's
the feature it was they're all sharing
as opposed these their local impacts I'd
like to you know sort of further promote
the concept of using for models because
you know all of these records come from
individual studies which were done by
you know these authors who are have all
this local expertise and really
understand the nuances and the
complexity of the individual records
that they've developed and what they
might be sensitive to and whether or not
and it's really hard to communicate that
complexity from all these of individual
authors and papers into a synthesis that
combines you know several hundred to put
you know you know five hundred eleven
records and so by by by formalizing that
that sort of scientific understanding of
how each site in each proxy filters
climate into its sort of archive signal
formula isn't that into a sort of what
they've been calling a foreign model is
a really powerful way
sort of embedding that scientific
understanding which for a lot of these
these proxies goes back because you know
many decades into that record so that
you know further efforts like this can
really sort of incorporate that
understanding moving forward okay um we
have time for one quick question it's
just actually Florin narrowly and so
we've seen this upturn and all of these
prophecies really clearly except for
Antarctica can you tell us a little bit
what the signal in Antarctica is
actually showing or telling us about
climate there yes sir so in tactical air
in the in the continent paper doesn't
stand out as being a bit unusual all of
the other regions show that we have this
upturn where the long-term cooling trend
has been reversed that's not the case
for Antarctica and that's based on ice
core records that come from the central
part of Antarctica so I already
mentioned earlier that on the Antarctic
Peninsula that's not the case we do have
a significant warming on the Antarctic
Peninsula and that's probably closer to
the signal we see in South America and
and the reason that the Antarctic
Peninsula is warming quickly at the
moment and also why we get this rapid
increase in melting that we've been able
to show is because of the the westerly
winds that flow around Antarctica so we
have the peninsula that points out into
the southern ocean and those westerly
winds have been strengthening and that's
caused the peninsula to warm but it's
also isolated the continent so that
that's sort of one of the hypotheses as
to why Antarctica might still be cooling
I'm not showing a significant warming
and the the process that's thought to
drive that is the ozone depletion so I
think that there is a question that we
can look at by comparing the the
reconstructions with the model data and
looking at these forcing mechanisms what
can we explain with greenhouse gas
forcing what can we explain with ozone
forcing and and and as those things
change so the ozone hole is now sort of
at a level that's stabilized and more
slowly start to recover what can we
expect those
different effects to do in terms of
Antarctica so much so I can't believe it
but we're actually just about out of
time so I want to ask one concluding
question to everyone and that's the work
that's presented here represents pretty
much decades of work in our
understanding trying to understand how
climates varied over the last 2,000
years for each of you personally do you
have one burning question about climate
of the past 2,000 years that you want to
see answered you want to either work to
or see another group work to in the next
five years or so maybe I'll start with
Thorsten okay so being being faced I
have all the all the options and there
are actually two big questions I can
think of
well I'll mention only one to leave some
material for the other sand and that is
well precipitation because well now
we've focus on on temperatures but
temperatures actually in most cases not
what what what what matters to people
most it is much more water availability
and therefore we BBB have to get a
handle on
well actually projecting precipitation
patterns into the future and and to
facilitate that we we should get a
precipitation record spatially resolved
over the the reasons asked and of course
as you can probably tell we are about to
do exactly just that in the 2k magical
great thanks maybe to make it a bit
harder I should take this forward
modeling off the tables so we know we
want that we need to see that sorry if I
stole anyone's answer um I'm gonna go to
you now okay
the I think what moving forward what we
really need to do as a community is sort
of have a better understanding of
uncertainties and and how to communicate
this in certainties
from the sort of record level all the
way up through choose to the
reconstructions and especially sort of
spatial products and part of that is
this sort of really understanding what
your proxies tell you about climate
which is the form on which I won't go
into but there's a lot of other source
of uncertainty and I'm a really big one
that I think is really primed to make
progress in the next so decade is being
able to incorporate lower resolution
records and so the non annual and
especially ones would have time
uncertainty and so these records can
tell us a lot about climate over the
past 2,000 years but it's really hard to
incorporate them into these
reconstructions if when there is sort of
uncertainty on it when exactly this
estimate of temperature what you know
what year what decade to tie it to so
developing methods to handle uncertainty
in climate interpretation and an
uncertainty I think it's a big one the
chronologies great thanks narrowly yes I
think my thing would be similar to
toasting I'm looking at the the changes
that not just temperature but the things
that are actually going to influence
have more of an impact on society and so
and some of those things aren't linear
so there's something like ice melts
there is a clear threshold in the system
once the temperatures get above zero
degrees then you can actually you any
small increase in temperature then to
have a very large increase in melting so
understanding where those where there's
possibilities for changes that aren't
gradual maybe or for the feedbacks in in
the system so just getting a better
better handle on those and how they're
going to actually affect society
excellent and Gavin did anybody mention
for modeling but actually what well I
think that the key research task right
now is to find the the really
interesting diagnostics or metrics that
we can see in the models tell us
something about climate sensitivity or
tell us something about how changes are
going to go off in the future if we can
find metrics that are informative about
the future that we can constrain with
these kinds of datasets I think you know
people that find those and really look
for those I think those are going to be
the absolutely most essential elements
that come out of these synthesis in
there in the next few years really quick
follow-up yeah no one no one mentioned
the second priority I had in my mind and
that we had said that initially we had
records from the Northern Hemisphere and
now we filled in a lot of data in the
southern hemisphere but even believe
there's something in between the
northern and the southern hemisphere and
that is the tropics well and that is
tremendously underrepresented in terms
of data Africa is is is is an example
for that so that is a call to the
scientists of their producing records
trying to get something good from from
the tropics because there's a lot of
climate dynamics going on there that our
knowledge is really poor I hate to do
this but I think we're gonna have to
wrap this up if you want to take a look
at the pages paper it's actually free to
download for registered users until May
10 so just head over to the Nature
Geoscience homepage and download it from
there again just until May 10 before we
let you go I just want to say this was
our inaugural Nature Publishing Group
Journal Club and any feedback you have
would be great any Channel Twitter the
Google event page YouTube of schemes and
memes let us know we want to improve and
make this even more fun for you and fun
for us so with that I'd like to thank
you all for watching and I hope we'll
see you the next time we do that all
right thanks